okay so we are now going to do the third
part in our sort of trilogy of uniquely
human functions
so starting a few weeks ago we moved
from things that are shared with animals
like navigation
and basic visual perception very similar
between humans and monkeys
and uh other uh number all of these
things that are shared uh with animals
to talk about functions that are
uniquely human and that includes music
and language and today we're going to
talk about the coolest and most
quintessentially human mental function
is and that is thinking about each
other's thoughts
so
to get started thinking about this
um let me remind you guys of what should
be pretty obvious that we human beings
are profoundly social in many many
different respects
so
if you think about you know if you
recount what happened in your day to
someone else pretty much all of the
elements of what you're encoun
recounting
our interactions with other people these
are the things we care about these are
the basic structure of our lives
um other people are the source of our
greatest happiness for most of us if you
ask people at the end of life what
matters most they'll say i shouldn't
have wasted all that time working so
hard and my job didn't matter and i
didn't realize actually it's just other
people are the only thing that matter
interactions with other people or lack
thereof are also
the source of one of the deepest kinds
of human suffering for many of us
whether it's an everyday thing like a
breakup with a or with a with a lover or
a loss of a loved one or a family member
um and also depriving people of social
interactions this is like society's um
kind of strongest form of punishment
right is solitary confinement
um
interactions with other people um our
failure to understand them is
devastating in the case of autism where
people struggle to understand
what other people are all about
and
in terms of our
amazing abilities as human beings most
of what we know
we learn from other people sometimes we
figure stuff out on our own
but if you take an inventory of all the
stuff you know
you read about it or somebody told it to
you you learned it from other people
and consequently some of the greatest
feats of humanity from arts to science
to everything else
are products of people working together
okay
further many people have hypothesized
that social cognition our ability to
understand and deal with interact with
other people
is one of the strongest drivers of the
evolution of the human brain so many
have argued that the hardest problem we
solve on a daily basis is understanding
other people
and it's also a very important problem
and so that's a powerful
natural selection force understanding
other people and that has shaped the
structure of the human brain not
everybody agrees with that kind of
extreme view that it's the primary
driver but it's an interesting
hypothesis and it surely played some
role
social cognition also is just a very
large percent of human cognition and
it's a large percent in terms of minutes
of every day
if you tally up different forms of
social cognition this is one we're doing
right now and we're about to engage in
an hour and 20 minutes of it right here
and probably when you leave this room
you'll engage in other kinds of social
cognition so it's just a large percent
of what we do all day every day
and it's also a large percent of what
the cortex does
so
roughly that stuff and other bits
are engaged in different aspects of
social cognition
so what exactly is social cognition
to get a sense of what is entailed in
social cognition which is a very complex
multi-part multi-faceted
enterprise i'm going to show you a um a
short video of an interaction between an
8 a bunch of 18 month old infants and an
experimenter and what i want you to do
is just watch it it's very charming but
also think about what these kids must
know to be able to do what you're about
to see can you see the screen there okay
okay
that little kid in the corner doesn't
know this guy he's just been brought in
for the experiment and he's just
watching this weirdo doing this thing
put the eye contact
never met that guy before here's another
case
he's dropped a clothespin
what is the matter with this guy
[Laughter]
looking more and more suspicious
okay so what did you notice
what are those little kids 18 months oh
there's another one this is cute but we
don't need it let's go on
um
what did you notice about um
what those little kids were able to do
what what is entailed in being able to
do that what have they figured out
lots of things
yeah they understand intention
yeah
yeah all they're doing is watching this
guy do these clumsy actions and he's not
saying anything he's just grunting
and they're figuring out what he intends
absolutely what else
yeah
sort of being able to interpret
the sounds of the grunts that footage
was making so especially like the one
completion like
sound huh uh-huh yeah
one could ask which of those things are
more important actions or the sounds i
don't think they took it apart here but
it's an interesting question
yep so they they understand some kind of
vocal communication not language but
some kind of
intent definitely they'd be part of it
yeah
do you understand how to be helpful
without
coming in
i didn't hear without sorry without like
interviewing people
coming in their way
yeah yeah they know how to be helpful
but not just they know how they have a
will to be helpful
remember these kids never met that
stranger before this video started or
maybe a minute or two before
so it's fascinating not just what
they're able to figure out
but what they're motivated to do
right that's a quintessentially human
thing is to spontaneously help
a stranger who you've never met before
and
are not related to
right
okay
all right so but focusing more on the
cognitive abilities um what what you
need to do to figure out another agent's
actions is to figure out what that agent
is doing
and that's externally observable you can
watch you can use your perceptual system
construed broadly to figure out what is
this person doing in some general sense
and that's important and and subtle and
multifaceted but it's nowhere near
enough
really what you want to know is why are
they doing that thing
okay
and that's not directly observable you
can't see the why of a person's actions
you have to infer it in fact to infer
you have to infer a bunch of hidden
mental states and those things are much
more abstract than just you know i'm
picking up the phone right you know
that's just an action you can see it
but if you try to think about why am i
picking up the phone now we're in a
whole different ballpark
and so what you need to figure out to
hit to figure out the agent's hidden
mental states you need to figure out
what can that agent see or hear
okay
and here it's really important to not
lose a level here we're not talking
about
what we can see in understanding another
agent
we need to understand what what that
agent can see about someone else
okay so we're getting kind of meta here
with multiple levels okay
um we also need to understand
the other agents desires and goals of
what they want
or what they're intending okay
so how might we figure these things out
um sometimes there are simple cues that
might suffice so you might make an
inference like if a person is reaching
for an object they want that object
okay so there the externally observable
thing might give you a pretty direct
inference about that it hurt the
internal hidden state of what the what
the agent wants
okay but a lot of times that's not going
to work right that's going to work in
some cases but only a few
and further
the percepts and the goals that we've
mentioned here aren't enough
okay they'll work in some cases
but humans do much more than that
so let's consider this case
here's and here's a um
an agent
who's doing some action and we can
observe their body motions and what we
want to understand is how this other
agent watching them is going to infer
things about this guy okay so we're
interested in what's going on in the
mind of this guy as they watch that guy
okay now let's consider the case that
this guy's trying to understand
this is romeo here why did romeo reach
for the bottle
okay
well to understand why romeo reached for
the bottle
you need to perceive and infer a whole
bunch of things
you need to
see the hand reaching for the bottle to
know what happened
okay
but then to really understand the case
of romeo
you need to understand that his
intention is to drink the liquid in the
bottle that's why he reached for it
okay
can't see the intention to drink the
liquid you can only see the reaching
then you further need to understand why
is he intending to drink the liquid
well because he believes the liquid is
poison
um
i don't know why my pop-ups are all
messing up here whatever
he believes that julia is dead
and he wants to die
okay so all of that
is part of
what is entailed in understanding
why romeo reached for the bottle
okay
and crucially
the stuff in red
these things are the beliefs and desires
are not directly observable
they're
highly abstract
okay
and they're crucial they are the best
way to explain and predict behavior
so when we need to understand other
people and what they're doing and why
we're in this abstract space of beliefs
and desires we can't see them directly
we have to observe we have to infer them
indirectly
and they're essential because that's
what we need to do to understand other
people
okay
all right
so we talked before about perceiving uh
an agent um i'm sorry about inferring
what an agent can can perceive and
inferring the agent's desires and goals
but as i just pointed out we also need
to know the agent's beliefs what they
think
okay
so all of this stuff in here
inferring the hidden mental states of
agents
is what we mean by mentalizing inferring
other people's mental states
okay
and the cases we're talking about here
are inferring the percepts of another
agent
inferring the desires of another agent
and inferring the beliefs of another
agent
okay all this abstract stuff
okay
no computer system can do this not even
close see we can still say that we can't
say that about object recognition
anymore but we have this little precious
reserve where we can still say that
no animal can do these things except in
very restricted cases so there's an
active ongoing research program in a
bunch of labs testing chimps and subtle
tasks to try to figure out when they can
infer things about the mind of another
chimp or person and there are a few
restricted cases where they can make
some inferences about the mental
contents of other agents but the current
dominant view is that those inferences
are very restricted
to very particular situations usually
involving competition over food and they
don't generalize
um in in any way
okay so in this whole enterprise
specific cues like
making an inference that reaching for x
means wanting x will help in some cases
but will only get us so far
okay
we do much more than that and the
question is how
all right
all right so inferring mental states to
understand other people involves person
inferring their percepts their beliefs
and their desires
okay
um so how do we do this
well
a first question that we ask in this
class and that's kind of a sensible
thing to do is when we're trying to
understand this whole space of how
people think about another agent's
percepts beliefs and desires we might
just think okay maybe that's just part
of generic cognition who says that's a
separate domain of cognition that we
should study separately maybe we should
just study thinking in general thinking
about objects thinking about physics
thinking about people maybe it's all the
same thing
okay
so let's stop let's start by considering
is it really a separate thing from the
rest of cognition
okay
well there's a classic behavioral
paradigm in this field
that's provided some evidence in this
you may have heard about this in other
classes but we'll talk about it because
it's so kind of fundamental to all of
the work on
thinking about other people's thoughts
and that is called the false belief
paradigm
it's really a way of testing beliefs and
the reason you test false beliefs rather
than true beliefs is if you ask about
another agent's false belief true
beliefs
um then your prediction about what
they're going to do next is confounded
with what is true in the world and if
you want to really tap into what's going
on in their mind
as opposed to
what you know what would be true in the
world you have to use a false belief to
pull those apart
okay so the classic way this is done
the sally and task goes like this
this is the sound there are many
variants of it but this is the classic
original version
uh that appears in hundreds of papers
um so here's sally and and ann
and sally puts her ball in the basket
okay
you show this to little kids
or or animals too versions of it we're
doing a little kid version you say okay
here's sally she puts her ball in the
basket
uh
i don't know why my pop-ups are screwing
up anyway then ann comes along sally
leaves the room and comes in and moves
sally's ball from the basket to the box
and ann closes the top of the box
then the question is when sally comes
back
where will she look for her ball
okay where will she look for a
ball in the basket right
okay if you do this very simple question
for three-year-olds they'll say in the
box
if you do it on five-year-olds they'll
stay in the basket
okay adults say in the basket as you
guys say you have to think for a second
right if you just kind of blurt out the
first thing that comes to mind you'll
behave like a three-year-old and say in
the box
but if you think for half a second you
realize duh
she doesn't know it got moved to the box
she'll look where she thinks it is in
the basket okay everybody with the
program here okay so that's very very
simple task it's the basic false belief
paradigm
and to make it more vivid i have to show
you a video of rebecca sacks giving this
task to a bunch of kids and talking
about it it's a
it's a delightful video and it'll give
you a really vivid sense of
you know how smart a three-year-old is
and how much they understand and yet how
fundamentally and totally they fail this
task versions of this task
come on
here we go
the first thing i'm going to show you is
a change between age 3 and 5 as kids
learn to understand that somebody else
can have beliefs that are different from
their own so i'm going to show you a
five-year-old who's getting a standard
kind of puzzle that we call the false
belief test
this is the first pirate
his name is ivan
you know what pirates really like what
pirates really like cheese sandwiches
cheese i love cheese yeah so my friend
has his cheese sandwich and he says
i really love cheese sandwiches
when ivan puts his sandwich over here
on top of the pirate chest and ivan says
you know what i need a drink with my
lunch and so ivan goes to get a drink
and while ivan is away
the wind comes
and it blows the sandwich down onto the
grass
and now
here comes the other pirate
this parrot is called joshua
and joshua also really loves cheese
sandwich so joshua has a cheese sandwich
and he says
yum yum yum i love cheese sandwiches
and he puts his cheese sandwich over
here on top of the pirate chest so that
one is his that one's joshua's that's
right
and then his went down the ground yeah
that's exactly right now so he won't
know which one is his spontaneous don't
even have to ask
evan comes back and he says i want my
cheese sandwich
so which one do you think ivan's gonna
take
i think he's gonna take that one yeah
you think he's gonna take that one all
right let's see
oh yeah you were right you took that one
so that's a five-year-old who clearly
understands that other people can have
false beliefs and what the consequences
are for their actions now i'm going to
show you a three-year-old who got the
same puzzle and ivan says i want my
cheese sandwich which sandwich is he
gonna take
he's gonna take that one let's see what
happens let's see what he does here
comes ivan and he says
i want my cheese sandwich and he takes
this one
uh oh
why'd he take that one
[Music]
so the three-year-old does two things
differently first he predicts ivan will
take the sandwich that's really his
and second when he sees ivan taking the
sandwich where he left his where we
would say he's taking that one because
he thinks it's his the three-year-old
comes up with another explanation he's
not taking his own sandwich because he
doesn't want it because now it's dirty
on the ground so that's why he's taking
the other sandwich
now of course
development doesn't end at five and we
can see the continuation of this process
of learning to think about other
people's thoughts by upping the ante and
asking children now not for an action
prediction but for a moral judgment so
first i'm going to show you the
three-year-old again
i have been being mean and naughty for
taking joshua's sandwich yeah yeah
should i even get in trouble for taking
joshua sandwich yeah
so it's maybe not surprising he thinks
it was meena viven to take the joshua
sandwich since he thinks ivan only took
joshua sandwich to avoid having to eat
his own dirty sandwich
but now i'm gonna show you the
five-year-old remember the five-year-old
completely understood why i even took
joshua's sandwich was ivan being mean
and naughty for taking joshua's sandwich
[Music]
yeah and so it's not until age seven
that we get what looks more like an
adult response should i even get in
trouble for taking joshua's sandwich
no because the wind chicken
for switching sandwiches
okay so everybody got the idea of the
false belief tasks
past passed in the four and
five-year-olds not in the three-year-old
and the three-year-old not only fails to
get the answer right but when asked why
it happened he comes up with a totally
different account
okay and you can see that three-year-old
is not a dummy three-year-olds are smart
and can do all kinds of things but they
don't get this particular thing
okay
all right
what about kids with autism
well kids with autism
either fail this task altogether or they
pass it much later than neurotypical
kids
okay
but now
we've got to figure out why
why would a relatively high functioning
kid with autism say a seven-year-old
who's got language and who seems to
understand the question why would they
fail this task why would anybody fail
this task
there's a couple of things going on here
the essential element of the false
belief tasks that we're interested in is
that it requires you to attribute
thoughts to another agent right that's
what this task was made to tap
but you might fail it not just for
failing to attribute thoughts correctly
you might fail it for other reasons
you might fail it
because this task involves this weird
situation whereas there's the other
agent's belief and there's a reality and
they're different
and that's kind of confusing it's like
representing x and not x at the same
time maybe that's just a particularly
generically hard cognitive thing to do
okay
and the third possibility is that the
true state of the world is so salient
and dominant it may be hard to just
inhibit that true reality in order to
infer uh the the um the belief a belief
is a kind of less visible salient thing
than the true state of the world and so
maybe just having an inability to
inhibit dominant salient representations
would infer interfere with your ability
to do this task
so people with autism or in fact
three-year-olds
might fail for any of these reasons
so how are we going to figure out
whether people with autism are actually
failing this task
because of their difficulty and in
attributing thoughts
well the way to figure that out is to
come up with a really really clever
control task okay this task was invented
by debbie zaichik when i was in graduate
school she was my office mate in
graduate school and she came up with
this task and i said that is really
brilliant
so we want to figure out whether it's a
belief per se
uh that's the the
difficulty in attributing the thought or
the belief to another agent that's the
crux of the problem
so in zach's false photo task the idea
is it's a logically isomorphic task but
it's about a physical representation not
a mental one so what you do is
you
show
sally putting her her ball in the basket
uh and then you have a what was then
like widely known to
to kids a polaroid photograph a camera
come along
we didn't have cell phones back then so
it's a polaroid camera takes a picture
of
sally putting her ball in the basket
and then ann moves the ball from the
basket to the box and then you ask the
kid
why
where will
um
where will sally look for her ball i'm
sorry where will where is
sorry then you ask the kid where is the
ball in the photograph
okay
sorry i screwed it up here's a belief
version the kid watches sally and anne
in this case
you do a photograph version of it
so you there's no um you're not asking
about another person's beliefs you're
using a photograph and you're showing
sally put the ball in the basket basket
you take a photograph of it and moves
the ball to the box
and then you ask in the photograph
where's the ball
okay you're not asking amount about a
mental belief you're asking about a
physical representation in the
photograph
okay
so do you see how even though i bungled
it on the first time it's really a
logically isomorphic task you're in both
cases you're asking about a
representation that differs from reality
but one's a mental representation that's
where the kids with autism fail the task
this is the physical representation
kids with asd
fail the false belief task not the false
photo task
and that rules out these other accounts
because in both cases
there's a representation that differs
from reality you have the x and not x
challenge right that's true of both of
these
um and in both cases the true state is
kind of more dominant than the
representational state in the in the
belief or the photo
and yet they have a problem with the um
with the belief version not with a
photograph version suggesting that this
is the correct account of why they fail
that makes sense was there a question
yeah
okay
so all of that is consistent with the
idea that attributing uh thoughts to
another agent is a special distinctive
thing
that can be
that's what i just said
um so we have evidence that that that
attributing thoughts is a distinct
domain of cognition it's just not part
of your generic ability to think about
anything and we see that from the fact
that typical children have this very
systematic uh developmental time course
where they get this at age five they
don't get it at age three and we see it
from the selective loss of this ability
in
kids with autism
that they get the false belief task way
later than they get the false photograph
task was there a question here so the
kids are never asked what does amber see
that question then comes up in the fb
task in the fourth photograph task
um
i'm sure people have done versions of
that task but tell me what you're
getting at here i spoke
to do like an apocalyptic person i would
assume that the final question remains
the same so i would ask the kids
what do you think and perceives
uh given the change in the stimulus
and then the gate response given the new
media
as to what the actor you're trying to
get a tighter control to the false photo
task is that
yeah instead of where will she look for
the ball yeah um but it's not really
about what she perceives it's about
where she thinks the ball is
right
and so the the false belief tasks have
been done every which way from where
does sally think the ball is to where
will she look for the ball and you get
the same answer in all of those
so i think that's
that's closer to where is it in the
where is it in the photograph is really
where does she think it is that's that's
the that's the parallel
yeah because she's not still perceiving
it at that point
yeah
okay
so that's behavioral evidence to suggest
that there's really something different
about inferring another person's
thoughts and beliefs than there is from
the rest of cognition the distinctive
developmental time course and this kind
of selective deficit and autism so what
can we learn from functional mri is
there a special part of the brain for
making these inferences about other
agents thoughts and beliefs
okay
so rebecca and i did this experiment 100
years ago
where we scanned people while they were
doing simple simple verbal tasks so we
wrote false belief
stories and sort of false photo stories
generalized
and we scanned people while they lay in
the scanner and just read these simple
descriptions and answered basic
questions so you can try this right now
here's a false belief story
um your you read susie parked your
sports car in the driveway in the middle
of the night nathan moved her car into
the garage to make room for his minivan
susie woke up early in the morning
susie expects to see in the driveway a
sports car or a minivan yes
sports car
right exactly what she thinks is there
not what is there the control um
experiment that we wrote many many of
these a volcano erupted on this
caribbean island three months ago baron
lava rock is all that remains
satellite photos show the island as it
was before the eruption
in the photos the island is covered in
rock or vegetation
right
okay so
here um
again it's just like debbie zach's asd
control here it's you're asking about a
representation in the satellite photo
that's no longer true of reality and you
have to distinguish the two
so we scan people just doing these tasks
okay
and if you look
in a whole brain group analysis that i
was much dissing before but that's a
good first step
you see here's a slice through the brain
like this you see a bunch of hot spots
that respond more when you do these
tasks than those tasks
okay
and there's a bunch of these regions
deep down in the middle of the
prefrontal cortex here that you can see
in a slice like that here is a region
called mpfc for medial prefrontal cortex
it does all kinds of interesting things
and it'll get mostly short shrift in
this lecture it activates in this tab
and for reasons you'll see in a minute
activates in this task
um
oh god i'm pop-ups or
have a mind of their own
uh but here's another region the right
tpj tpj stands for temporoparietal
junction so in me if my temporal lobe is
going down here my parietal lobe is here
frontal lobe is there temporopridal
junction is somewhere right around there
okay
everybody oriented
and if we look at that region shown
symbolically here
what you see
in the time course of response in that
region doing this task is here's what
happens in that region
this is time here many seconds as they
read and answer that task and here's
what happens when they read and answer
uh the false photo task so false belief
tasks false photo task that just shows
you the same thing as activation yeah
you can see it evolve over time
okay
so um
what happens in the npfc region
oh god why is this not happening
is that showing up oh there it is okay
um right in the mpfc region you see a
similar thing
you get a response below baseline here
we'll talk about that what it means to
have a response below baseline in some
conditions in the next lecture
it's actually not all that mysterious it
just means that baseline remember is
usually lying in the scanner staring at
a dot going dumb dw dumb or whatever you
do when you're staring at a dot in the
scanner
and uh the key point for now is just
that you also see a higher response to
the belief than photo case okay okay
so what's going on in these regions
this activation this higher response to
the belief than photo case even though i
was touting what a brilliant control
condition the false photo task is it is
but it's still open to a bunch of
different possibilities
okay so that act those activations
could be just
thinking about a person after all our
false belief stories all involve people
and our false photo stories did not
so maybe this isn't about beliefs per se
it's just about thinking about people in
general any any aspect of people
okay
or it could be
any mental inference we make about the
internal invisible states of a person
okay
any anything that might be going on in
their head
or it might be particularly attributing
thoughts and desires to the person
okay
so how are we going to unconfound these
with a new experiment and some new
conditions so here's a new condition
that refers just to a person not about
their internal invisible states or their
thoughts or desires
subjects just read simple stories like
i see what's happening
it's not showing it's showing something
different on the screen from what's on
my slide here
i have no idea why but anyway that's why
i keep
wondering what's there and what's not
okay
um okay
so in the external case in this
condition you lie in the scanner you
read stuff like andrew just had a growth
spurt so he was gangly and rather
awkward like most teenagers he had bad
skin and bad taste in clothes he wore
mostly baggy jeans and flannel shirts
okay so it's you know it's not riveting
but it's not boring either you read a
bunch of these they're interesting
enough okay
but no mental states there just outward
appearance
okay
the next condition refers directly to
the person's thoughts nikki
nikki knew that his sister's flight from
san francisco was delayed 10 hours only
one flight was delayed so much that
night so when he got to the airport he
knew what flight was hers
okay not even that interesting
but it's talking about what he inferred
what he knew beliefs okay
but there's a third condition
that refers to an internal state but not
a thought or a belief refers to a
visceral state
sheila skipped breakfast because she was
late for the train to her mother's by
the time she got off the train she was
starving her stomach was rumbling and
she could smell food everywhere
okay so this case is interesting it's
vivid it refers to a mental state but
not a thought it's a physical state
hunger
okay
i mean it's a it's a mental
representation of a bodily sensation
okay
everybody get the distinction between
internal thoughts and
and and feelings sensations okay
so ah this contrast is consistent with
any of these hypotheses and we're going
to test those hypotheses with these
three conditions
okay
so
here are the three
hypotheses we just described here and
here are the three conditions i just
gave and i want you guys to tell me what
we're going to predict that we will see
in the right tpj
according to each hypothesis which
namely which of these conditions will
produce a high response and which will
produce a low response
okay so let's start with this case
on the hypothesis that the right tpj
responds whenever you're reading about a
person
what are we going to find
which of these conditions is going to
produce a height response
all of them yeah absolutely so that's a
prediction here all of them
okay
what about if it's interested in
internal
internal bodily sensations
or or actually in in any internal mental
states
the last two absolutely both the
visceral case and the thoughts case
sorry that cell in that cell okay and
what about if it's specifically about
attributing thoughts to another agent
just the last one right
okay very good
so what do we see
so first of all here's just the
localizer task always nice to look at
your localizer and make sure it worked
out so this is a response of the right
tpj to the belief and photo condition
just like i showed you before higher
when you do the belief tasks and the
photo task okay just a reality check key
question what is the response of the
right tpj in that main experiment with
the three conditions we just described
and here's what it does
it's high only in the thought condition
only when you're when you're reading
about thinking about another person's
thoughts
and that's significantly higher than
either the
external properties or the um this uh or
the visceral states
and those two even though it looks like
there's a little bit of a trend that
visceral is higher than external that's
not significant
yeah
um on the previous slide is it like
thoughts and desires
so like
why can't
like i was just confused about like the
example for the bristol case for
smelling food everywhere like couldn't
that fall under it that's a good point
yes it could yes you could infer a
desire in that case absolutely yeah
that's right um so yeah that's a good
point it's intended to just identify the
vivid visceral state
uh and it's probably hard to do that
with it without invoking some kind of
desires here
um yeah i would i would consider it a
con a confound for that particular
example
um i'm guessing it was not so for the
others in fact
um it sort of couldn't have been given
the way this came out
right
but good point
okay so um
okay so and if you do a whole
group analysis
of the whole brain and you say what bits
do you get in a contrast of reasoning
about another person's thoughts versus
their external appearance or their
visceral states
uh their bodily sensations you get
the right tbj again
okay so everybody got this to suggest
that the right tpj is extremely specific
uh specifically interested in inferring
another person's thoughts not even just
their bodily sensation so it's not all
mental states of another person that
engage this region i mean i find this
quite remarkable because that's so
specific you know but before you hear
about this you think okay thinking about
another person's thirst or hunger or
pain is that really different than
thinking about their beliefs but oh yes
it's different right the tpj does
beliefs not thirst and hunger and pain
yes
yeah so there's a whole literature on
this
and um
uh i think if you
okay so first of all we need to like get
the level straight
when you're just thinking
you're not thinking about thinking
you're just thinking right so you're not
engaging this region right so when we're
talking about thoughts and we're talking
about you thinking about another
person's thoughts
so the parallel would be you thinking
about your own thoughts right
so i think you know i
i can't tell you exactly what the
literature is on this i'm sure there's a
few experiments but i think what you'd
have to do is
adopt that kind of meta
perspective on yourself right a lot of a
lot of our thinking is sort of thinking
about thinking but not in a very
explicit
separable way i'm not being very clear
on this but
um you know i think if you asked if you
ask people for example
um
you know
when you saw this surprising event
whatever it is you make something up
what were you thinking
uh you might engage that region
i realize i'm not totally sure if
there's literature on this heather is
there there must be literature on this
so they've done some inspiration
you get mpfc for that yeah
well go ahead well we just thought i'd
talk about this
and um it's kind of like insert but it's
either
so they're they're both two networks
that are particularly clear but not just
rtpga right rtbj and other regions
yeah so you could get some rtbj when
answering those kinds of questions
okay so you get something in the
vicinity i'm just trying to
get
okay so
uh-huh
right
but the other part of this is i bet you
have to do something quite explicit to
do that because in some sense we're
thinking about our own thoughts kind of
implicitly a lot of the time right so
i'm guessing that it's
when you ask about it explicitly
yeah i i forget details of the past but
it was very
great about this
right
next to you
right
okay anyway good question i'm sorry i
don't have a totally adequate answer yet
i'm guessing the literature doesn't have
a totally adequate answer yet
um okay
all right um
so recall that i uh mentioned that the
uh the contrast between doing the false
belief task versus the false photo task
gets not just the rtbj it also gets this
medial frontal region
okay and that needle frontal region
responds more to the belief than
photograph task like this
what does it do
in this split between
uh thoughts visceral thinking about
other people's thoughts their visceral
states and their external appearance
it doesn't care
okay so there's a real division
between these different brain regions
that are engaged when you do the false
belief task the rtbj is very
specifically interested in
very specifically engaged when you think
about another person's thoughts not when
you think about their bodily sensations
the medial prefrontal region
is engaged in all three of these
conditions
okay
so
what it looks like
is that of these three hypotheses
anytime you think about another person
that's true of the mpfc
whereas
the right tpj
responds specifically when you attribute
thoughts and when you
and desires to another person
okay
okay
now you may have been wondering about
the fact that all of these experiments
are using words it's kind of not like
normal social cognition you're reading
about all this stuff
um and if these regions were really
doing what we're claiming they're doing
we should be able to find them in other
situations where you make inferences
about other agents beliefs
so
in more recent experiments
they've been showing pixar movies to
subjects in the scanner so you can just
watch yourself make a few
inferences about the agent's beliefs
imagine you're watching this in the
scanner
and just let's just do a little bit of
it to get the gist
[Music]
no words it's the key
okay so there's a whole little microcosm
of uh mental states here uh in other
parts of this same six-minute pixar
movie
there's very vivid bodily sensations
there's a porcupine who inflicts real
pain with porcupine quills so there's
bodily states and
inferences about bodily states and
inferences about mental states that go
on
and by um showing this movie to subjects
in the scanner and then labeling which
parts of the movie require the viewer to
make inferences about the thoughts and
beliefs of the protagonists and which
require them to make inferences about
bodily sensations like usually pain
if you do that contrast
you find
the same set of regions the rtbj and its
left hemisphere bit
and you find some medial prefrontal
stuff and you find some other stuff
okay so what does that mean that means
that you don't need words to identify
this region you if you induce the same
cognitive processes just from watching a
a wordless movie
um you show the same selective
activations
um and that's cool because it tells us
that uh this is not about some kind of
verbal reasoning it's really about the
kind of deeper cognitive process whether
you do it based on a movie or based on a
bunch of sentences
um and that's a powerful generalization
we we like uh imaging results
where the result generalizes across very
different kinds of tasks and this this
really strengthens the evidence that
this is really what's going on in this
region
and it also means you can look for this
region in kids
okay and i didn't manage to fit that
into this lecture but there's a whole
other research enterprise where
in rebecca's lab
they've been scanning kids watching this
pixar movie and asking how that region
develops
and they find
that actually the region continues to
develop even after age four
it continues to develop and what happens
is it doesn't uh it doesn't so much get
bigger as it gets more selective
in the younger kids you get activation
both for um
well it's just less selective
anyway so uh this shows generalization
so now we've shown
um that we see the rtbj is selective for
thinking about other people's thoughts
we see that with false photo false
belief versus false photo contrast
we see that it's highly specific it's
not just any thoughts you have about
another person
and we see it generalizes depicts our
movies okay
okay
so let's consider now moral reasoning
as a test case for theory of mind
why moral reasoning
well if you think about it reasoning
about what's a morally acceptable or
unacceptable action on the part of
another person
is all about
what the person intended
and what they knew
okay so intent is very fundamental it's
built into the legal system think about
the difference between murder and
manslaughter
right they both involve killing another
person but one is with intent and the
other is accidental and our
you know common moral reasoning and our
legal system cares deeply about that
difference okay
um
okay
so for example i'm going to give you a
moral reasoning task
uh and just think about this and your
your task is going to be to decide how
morally
permissible is the action described here
um grace's action in particular okay so
grace and her friend are taking a tour
of a chemical plant
and when grace goes over the coffee
machine to pour some coffee
grace's friend asks for some sugar in
hers
and there's white powder in a container
by the coffee
the plot thickens
the white powder is a very toxic
substance left behind by a scientist and
therefore it's deadly when ingested in
any form
versus
a butt the white the container is
labeled sugar
so grace believes that the white powder
by the coffee is sugar left by the
kitchen staff
so grace puts the substance in her
friend's coffee
and her friend drinks a coffee and dies
now your question
is how morally permissible was grace's
action on a scale from one
to totally not okay morally forbidden to
seven
morally permissible okay so think about
that on a scale
and write down your number on a piece of
paper you don't have to divulge it
okay
everybody got the question
everybody decided more or less
okay write down your number
now consider a slightly different case
slightly but crucially different case
this case is known as the accidental
harm case
now consider the case where instead
okay
instead of being labeled sugar
you get the same story but now the
container is labeled toxic so grace
believes that the white powder is a
toxic substance
left behind by a scientist
nonetheless she puts the substance in
her friend's coffee and their friend
drinks a coffee and dies now consider
how morally permissible is grace's
action
from one to
totally not okay to seven
morally permissible
and write down your number
okay
okay how many people gave a lower number
that is more morally forbidden for the
second one than the first one
okay
if you didn't you probably weren't
paying attention
okay
so
you can see that it's the crux of the
matter what grace believed when she did
the action
okay that's why we're talking about
moral reasoning here as a test case of
theory of mind
because what the agent knew at the time
of the action is of the essence and
thinking about the moral status of their
action okay everybody got that
okay so this is a powerful test case and
notice that also in the clip that i
showed you from rebecca's ted talk
she showed that um
kids ability to use
an agent's knowledge in doing what you
guys just did that kicks in a little bit
later than the standard false belief
task
so sometime after they get the basic
idea of false belief they start to apply
it takes a while to
to kick in in this other case
okay
so this is known as intentional
intentional harm as opposed to
accidental harm
okay it's just the terminology in the
field
um okay so
what do you think will happen in autism
if we ask people with autism
these two questions
and what do you think will happen
if we apply tms to the right tpj
it's right out there on the lateral
surface
just asking for it so it's a totally
doable experiment
it's been done
what do you think happens
okay let's take the case with autism how
do you think people with autism will
respond to these two questions
the same as you guys did
yeah
yes char duel
probably like the average distance
between
the average distance between how bad
they think the second one just be less
than
yes exactly why
um
because they might not be able to make
the distinction between
grace knowing that the container was
toxic versus the container being labeled
toxic
it's like both of them would be
confounded which is like truth of how
the women's
absolutely absolutely everybody get that
and share that intuition to the extent
that autism
is a particular deficit in understanding
what another person knows or believes
that's the only difference between these
two cases to the extent that you have
difficulty representing that
you will have less of a difference in
your moral judgment about these two
things because you have a hard time
representing that person's knowledge
it's not that autism is a deficit in
moral reasoning it's that moral
reasoning
entails thinking about other people at
least these cases not all of it but
these cases involve thinking about other
people's thoughts and taking them into
account and to the extent that that's
difficult for you you will make less of
a distinction exactly right yeah was
there a question begging
yeah okay
okay
what do you think will happen
if you zap the rtbj
with tms while subjects are doing these
tasks
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah that's the prediction if the rtbj
is the main bit that's doing the
inference about that's representing the
beliefs of others
then if you zap it you might change
people's moral
inferences more moral judgments
that's pretty wild
that's what happens
except the rtpj and they make a smaller
distinction between accidental harm and
incident and intentional harm
okay so both of those things are true i
won't drag you through all the details
of the experiments
but the the basic findings from this
whole line of work show that first of
all
neurotypical people
agree as you guys did that accidental
harm is more morally permissible than
intentional harm okay
and people with
autism give less forgiveness for
accidental harm
compared to intentional harm than
neurotypicals okay just because they
that ability to represent the key
knowledge that that tells you it's
accidental is something they're not good
at
okay
what is the role of the rtpj the data
show that forgiveness for accidental
harms
first of all i left this out before it's
correlated in neurotypicals with
activation of the right tbj during moral
judgment
so if you just measure across a whole
bunch of those moral judgment problems
how strongly activated was your rtpg as
you read that problem
that's correlated with your ability to
forgive somebody for accidentally
harming someone again showing that
there's a relationship between
you're representing the thoughts and
beliefs of another person and you're
using that information to exonerate them
from a harm they didn't intend yeah
is it different for for thoughts versus
external actions
yeah um so um so first of all i'm i'm
treating autism very superficially here
it's an extremely hetero heterogeneous
thing that varies not just you know
along a spectrum you know which it
clearly does but probably along many
spectra and it's highly heterogeneous
so these experiments are just done in
high functioning adults
who are you know totally past false
belief tasks
um they pass them later in life but they
get to you know otherwise you can't test
them on these kinds of experiments
and the effects are quite subtle they're
just a slightly lesser difference
between accidental and intentional harm
okay so just to clarify that which i
probably should have said but your
question is are the uh deficits in
autism specific to thinking about
thoughts rather than thinking about
actions
this is ongoing work but a lot of
research has shown that that it it is
more specific to thoughts
and that a lot of the stuff you read
about just basic perceptual um
difficulties i mean
most studies find that people with
autism are a little bit worse at face
recognition
but not much worse
in tasks asking about
goals of actions like reaching for
objects what is that person's intention
mostly they don't find a deficit in
autism
so the perceptual basics
seeing people and seeing what they're
doing
is much less impaired that's what the
current literature suggests there's
always the worry that you know we're not
asking in the right way or testing in
the right way
um and the literature is highly
inconsistent from one study to the next
i used to work on autism and i just you
know couldn't stand it anymore because
every time a study is done it gets the
opposite of the previous study i think
because the population's so
heterogeneous but from a gloss it looks
like there's more of a deficit in the
inferences about thoughts than
inferences about actions
yeah i just want to clarify so the
autistic subjects are also explicitly
told that grace believes lovable yes
it's explicitly uh no it's exactly what
i
uh gave here
uh yeah no grace believes yeah you're
right grace believes yes explicitly
and in spite of that it's known
yep
yeah
yeah and so i think you can think of
this as a subtle case these are people
who
pass the explicit false belief task
but like the seven-year-old kids there's
one thing if you're asked what does this
person believe and another if you're
asked a moral reasoning task for which
you have to realize to bring the belief
into account you know it takes more
of your own kind of active was there
another question what if you ask like
instead of grace what did you say to me
what if what you ask them like about
themselves so
you are you and your friends are
thinking it's more of a chemical times
and giving them the exact same scenario
would that be any different
um yeah that's interesting it's like the
question about
uh you know to what
sorry
question is suppose you ask people with
autism this same question but it's not
about grace it's about you you do all of
this
um i'm not sure good question probably
somebody's looked at that yeah i'm not
sure if they answered this already but
uh do people with autism have something
different in their art
we're getting there
you should absolutely be wondering that
and i haven't yet and we're getting
there good that you ask in fact that's
probably my very next slide
um okay
um okay so causal role
we showed the causal role of the rtpg in
neurotypical subjects you zap the rtbj
and you
slightly reduce the difference in moral
permissibility of the accidental harms
and the intentional harms okay so all of
these findings suggest that the rtbj is
causally engaged in understanding the
difference between intentional and
accidental actions
and that that ability is specifically
disrupted in autism
all of which leads to the natural
prediction that genealogists made about
the rtbj
in autism
so what do you think is rtbj affected in
autism
how many raise your hand if you think
there's going to be something different
in the rtbj and autism versus typical
subjects
okay raise your hand if you think there
isn't
not sure
okay well you sort of both write in
different ways okay
so
the answer is this so so um
uh in rebecca sax's lab they did a study
with a
a really large number of typical
subjects it's you know because of this
heterogeneity
in the autism population it's really
hard to get a stable result you can
believe
so and it helps to have a really large
it's hard to get enough autism subjects
so we try and get as many as we can and
the most you ever get in a study around
here is you know 20 30 and that's a big
struggle
but it helps to have a really large
neurotypical control population to
reduce your error bars on what the
neurotypical population shows so this
study is probably the biggest that's
been done they had 31 high functioning
people with autism
and 462
neurotypical individuals
they didn't just go run 400 new subjects
for this when you when you run that
localizer task you've got it in every
study you run and so then you can take
all those localizer tasks across
hundreds of subjects so
um and so what they find is um both if
you look at regions of interest analysis
like find the rtbj
and if you do a whole brain
group analysis you find
no differences between people with
autism
high functioning people with autism and
typical subjects in the size location or
response magnitude of the rtbj
um
okay
when people do theory of mind tasks
so you should be surprised
everyone is surprised you all made the
prediction everyone else made the
prediction too
um and that's pretty bizarre
um
but
does that mean that the rtbj is not
affected in asd
chardool
the
information from the rpmpj is not used
by other parts of the brain
it's a great hypothesis maybe the
information is in there and it's some
kind of a disconnection thing and so it
can't you know could be accessed by
other processes
right absolutely what's another
hypothesis
yeah is bill
sorry
in a different order what do you mean
yeah but then we'd have to think about
how the different temporal order would
lead to the different behavioral
outcomes right am i
yeah david
maybe he's given a different priority
so like what you're processing there
might not be as
important to
the person itself
yep okay so it might be there but less
salient or less important
but how is that going to account for the
lack of a difference between
the asds and typicals remember
you run your basic false belief versus
false photo contrast and you find the
rtpj
and surprisingly even in this fairly
large sample it looks the same in size
location and response magnitude
in the asds and in the typicals
now i left something out this is this is
high functioning adult asds who can now
pass the false belief task right that's
crucial because that's the task you're
doing in the scanner they don't
understand the task there's no point
scanning them kind of going huh what
right so these are people who are you
know very high functioning and they can
totally do the task right otherwise you
can't run the experiment
um
so
yes what are the behavioral differences
well that's a very good question that's
another reason that i stopped working on
autism
there's a whole there's a whole battery
that you run to try to establish that
you know these people officially really
for the purposes of scientific study
count as having autism and these people
really officially don't at mit you need
to run those studies on everyone because
some of your control subjects end up in
the other group
um and um
and and so those are a whole kind of
battery of things from you know
involving an hour-long interview with a
trained person who tallies things like
how much eye contact is made and what
kind of give and take happens in
conversation and all that kind of stuff
i just don't
i guess for the experiment because i
mean yeah
their behavioral response might not
necessarily be hard to be changed
yeah
absolutely so yes it's possible that the
rtpj is absolutely fine in people with
autism and there's no difference as
those initial results seem to suggest
and that whatever
differences you see with autism reside
elsewhere but that's surprising given
all the stuff i've said over the last
hour about how
uh at least you know um in the case of
moral reasoning
these same high functioning the same
people who show the same activation of
the rtbj have slightly different moral
reasoning right so there's yeah
like or so for moral reasoning for
example could be
what they
base their morals off but might not be
intended to survive like at that point
in their life
different idea of what more other people
mentioned
yep
that's true yep never in this test um
they function the same way the people
who are being examined are yes in the
same way yes the difference
so why don't they test them without
performing those good
good
exactly so we're in this funny position
of
we've sort of identified you know theory
of mind
um inferences as a as a critical
difficulty in autism but these are
people the only ones we can scan on that
kind of task are people who can already
pass it so we're already in a weird
situation now you might have predicted
that they could pass it based on other
cognitive abilities right that they
they um come up with another strategy
and in that case they wouldn't be using
their rtbj but another hypothesis is it
just develops later they've got it there
it is they use it it activates the same
that's yeah and so your point is why
don't they test some of the moral
reasoning tasks right and see if it
comes online
right
well the one that they can't function on
because exactly maybe they don't know
when to use them that's right
that's right that's right it's a it's a
very good suggestion that's probably
been done and i don't know this heather
do you know if people scanned
asds doing the moral reasoning task
probably leanne has done that right
it's a really good suggestion and and i
actually now can't think why they
wouldn't have done that do you mind just
going on pubmed and look it would be
leanne
young and it would be um yeah moral
reasoning from fmri i bet she's done
that
maybe heather will get you this because
it's a very good suggestion yeah why not
test them on the thing that's different
okay anyway
um what i'm what i'm getting at here is
you know all these hypotheses you guys
are raising are very good ones but
there's another one which is maybe the
rtbj isn't functioning right even though
we see it activated more
when they do the false belief task than
the false photo task
maybe we'd see a difference if we looked
at the pattern of responses in there
right
okay
all right so um
in this study um
uh
koster hale and sax did something that
should be very familiar to you guys
they took these two cases sort of a
version of what you're suggesting
yeah maybe it does entail it i think of
it as an mvpa experiment but actually
heather that's the thing to look at is
does koster hale see a difference in
overall magnitude
and that i don't know anyway they did
the mvpa version so you have subjects do
those same tasks the accidental harm the
intentional harm you split your data in
half and you ask whether the rtpj
represents the difference between
accidental harm and intentional harm
okay everybody get why this is a
sensible thing to do
okay so first you do that in um
neurotypical subjects okay
um and you find here is the court
remember this is the original hacks b
version the correlation within versus
correlation between
so this is a correlation within and
that's correlation between
so this is accidental the pattern in the
rtpj for accidental harm to accidental
harm across stories
and intentional to intentional is higher
than from accidental to intentional here
i'm sort of skipping over the details
hoping you guys remember this is this
making sense
okay so typical um
classification with with correlations
and you see that that was significant in
this group of subjects
uh of typical subjects okay so that's
cool so there's information in the rtvj
about whether
um an action was intentional or
accidental that's cool now we've learned
something more than just it activates
when you do these tasks we know
something about what it represents
but you might say
that's so teeny
ick yeah it was significant but really
so what do you do in that case
do it again absolutely
you don't go find some fancier stat that
gets your p level so you have to start
no no no no you do it again
rebecca and her lab members being good
scientists did it again and they got the
same thing
excellent
new bunch of subjects new bunch of
stories
replicate and generalize do it again
and so yes indeed
we can
the spatial pattern contains information
further
you can then again in this bunch of
neurotypical subjects look at the degree
to which
subjects rated the moral permissibility
to be different in the intentional and
accidental look at their behavioral
ratings during the task
that's here and you can see that's
correlated with the degree of pattern
information in the rtbj
okay everybody get that so the more you
pay attention to that distinction
behaviorally when you're doing the task
the more you think accidental harm is
really much more okay than intentional
harm the greater that difference
in your behavioral ratings the greater
the discrimination ability in your rtbj
while you're doing it
okay so that's a further length that
that's where the action is
just a correlation not causation but
it's a nice one
yeah
okay
so all of this is yeah
yes
it's in the rtc party technically
as means there's no certain people
between us always going to
presentational horses and there is a
communications so
nurse of course ohio
have a difference in the congregation
just univariate overall magnitude
accidental versus intentional
in neurotypicals
but not in asds aha so it's not just a
pattern result yeah
it's in the text it's not
okay
okay okay
um
okay but that's the interaction
uh-huh
okay
but then the version of nava's question
which i resonate to very much is if you
just did the original kind of dufour
thing of
is the rtbj just as big and selective
and is it in the same place
just
because
it was a huge
that's true okay so they don't have the
data
okay
okay fair enough
okay good point okay so that's why you
know you ask that question it's a very
good question i'm thinking yes they
should have done that reason they didn't
do it is
they could have the big sample because
they were using localizer data which
they had from study after study after
study every time you run a theory of
mind test you run that localizer and
then you just go back a few years and
you've got 300 subjects right
but they didn't run the moral reasoning
task on hundreds of subjects and so they
don't have the power to be able to see
it yeah
okay fair enough okay so back to this
this is just showing that in the
neurotypical subjects um
there's pattern information in the rtpj
about intentional versus accidental harm
everybody got that and it's correlated
with your behavioral reading of the
moral permissibility
okay
so that's cool
um
so does rtpj distinguish between
accidental and intentional harm in asds
okay so these are the data i just showed
you actually they did three experiments
showing this here into endurotypicals
and here's the asd data no difference at
all
okay so
so what that means is
even though asds have the same size and
location
and magnitude of response of the rtbj in
the standard localizer task as typical
subjects
the key difference that's been found so
far is that in neurotypical subjects our
tpj
holds information about the distinction
between intentional and accidental harm
in in asds it doesn't
okay
that's probably just one of a bunch of
things that are going to be different
this is as far as i know the only one
that's been published that sees i see
some squints are you not getting this or
do you have a question about it yeah
what happens in the evidence
uh the fault there isn't an obvious
discrimination that you can do see the
the nice thing about the moral reasoning
task is it's got these two outcomes
these two um conditions accidental harm
and intentional harm so that gives us a
way to go in and do the pattern analysis
question there so with false beliefs
you'd have to think of some other
dimension
to look at
and it and the experiments are not set
up that way with with stimuli that are
on either side of a
of a dichotomy so that you can do the
discrimination
you could do representational similarity
analysis actually come to think of it
then you wouldn't have to have the whole
dichotomy
that's interesting
okay heather
has rebecca done that you're my
informant here
you could take
okay so
um shash is suggesting um what you know
why not do this kind of ask this kind of
question of this standard localizer
experiment and i said well it wasn't set
up with an obvious
dichotomy
um and
and then i was thinking actually you
could take all of the
belief conditions and you could do rsa
on those in the asds and on the typicals
and ask if their patterns are different
right i bet they've done that
see what i mean
anyway all right well i'll stop
speculating and just ask
she's right there two floors up can just
ask
all right uh anyway does everybody get
this basic idea here so the thing the
rtbg is there in the high functioning
people with autism but it doesn't hold
the same information
okay
all right
um
all right so where do we get with all of
this we used all of this stuff on moral
reasoning
as a way to look at the rtbj in theory
of mind
we found that
that
people with asd put less weight on a
person's beliefs when judging the moral
permissibility of an action
tms to the rtbj disrupts moral judgment
pattern analysis shows that the tpj
distinguishes between intentional and
accidental harm in neurotypicals but not
in people with asd
okay so there's a nice little story
developing here i'm sure it's not the
whole deal